education
this is the mitral valve of a dog's
heart
although you probably recognize it the
chances are that unless this particular
film before
you have not seen the action of the
valve from the inside
in the presentation to follow a variety
of shots have been taken from complete
film productions in different fields of
medical science
they have been assembled in order to
demonstrate the special qualities of the
motion picture which make it a unique
medium for teaching many subjects
it is hoped that this presentation will
act as a stimulus to greater use of the
many excellent teaching films now
available
this particular sequence showing heart
function was selected for inclusion
because it illustrates a situation in
which the motion picture can demonstrate
this material to a large audience better
than any other method
an animated diagram one of the important
teaching devices of the motion picture
is used at the beginning of this same
film on the mitral valve to explain the
basic setup of the experiment
the left side of the dog's heart has
been completely bypassed while the right
side continues to function
a pump drives the blood oxygenated in
the left lung only
through the cannula in the femoral
artery
to the lower limbs
and retrograde through the aorta to the
upper part of the body
back down the arch thus keeping the
aortic valve closed
a diagram before each section orients
the observer
in this view
the auricular side of the mitral valve
is seen
and as saline is washed into the
ventricle
one sees the aortic cusp billowing up
from the right side and furnishing about
three-fourths of the closure
the camera is thus able by photographing
the mechanical heart
to reveal certain aspects of the
dynamics of the mitral area
in cinematography of lymph vessels in
the mesentery of the rat
function may be observed microscopically
these spontaneous contractions of the
vascular wall are due to contractile
elements above the valves
here is the same scene in phase
microscopy
the lymph is propelled by the
peristaltic action
when the vessels relax the minute valves
close and prevent it from flowing back
dark field illumination shows the
contraction of the vascular wall and the
play of the valves particularly well
the fluoroscope provides yet another
tool for the study of physiology
with the development of new techniques
and photographic apparatus the moving
image on the screen may now be recorded
safely
by making repetitive prints
these may be used for unlimited future
study
as well as demonstration to many doctors
at the same time
no other medium can portray and teach
such phenomena to a large group together
these scenes show the movement of a
bolus and its propulsion into the
esophagus
the action of the soft palate
the glottis and other structures in the
region of the pharynx can be studied in
these revealing films
the wide variation possible in normal
swallowing is illustrated by this
demonstration of a beer drinker emptying
a full glass in a few seconds
this film excerpt shows a typical
laboratory setup used as an introduction
to mammalian experiments in physiology
a prescribed method for placing a
cannula in the femoral vein of a cap is
shown with generous use of close-ups
enabling the students to follow the
technique in detail
thus all students will approach their
own laboratory experiments with the same
background of experience
a background gained from observation of
the method the professor wants them to
follow
the acquisition of manual dexterity and
technical skill can come only from an
individual carrying out such experiments
himself
however where a demonstration is
performed first by the professor
film has definite advantages
it brings the details to all in the
classroom
it assures that the proper technique
will be shown each time
and that a successful outcome to the
experiment will occur
and last but not least
it saves laboratory animals
as an exhibit in pharmacology we take
advantage here of the split screen
technique to correlate heart action with
a simultaneous electrocardiographic
recording
an overdose of digitalis is given and we
see its progressive effects on the heart
a lengthened pr interval accompanies
evident changes in the character of the
beat
and idio-ventricular rhythms take over
the split screen technique is again used
by the pharmacologist in observing the
effect of various drugs on intestinal
motility
by placing the picture of a normal gut
above that of another after
administration of various drugs
a comparison of peristaltic action is
shown
such direct visual comparisons can
convey more than words in a text
and show the student what to expect from
his own experiments
the complicated process of embryology
can be pictured in the textbook only by
static illustrations
but the animated diagram can integrate
the stages of development and provide a
smooth flow of movement
from the embryology of the eye comes
this sequence on the development of the
lens
here the accompanying narration of the
film describes how the columnar cells in
the posterior portion of the vesicle
are seen steadily growing longer and
gradually obliterating the lumen
these are the primary lens fibers
in the audio visual concept of education
teaching is achieved by simultaneous
impact on eye and ear
thus by associating verbal symbols with
visual
the student is also learning
nomenclature
for example we return here to the script
as a second stage in development of the
lens begins once a roughly spherical
shape is achieved
in the region of the equator some of the
cuboidal cells elongate to form the
first secondary fibers
they are thick at the equator but taper
as they grow towards the front and back
of the lens
this picture explains that because they
can't become thin enough at the ends to
meet other fiber ends at a single point
a linear suture results
this film uses photomicrographs
interspersed at intervals to document
the sections shown in the diagrams
in the teaching of anatomy diagrams and
animation likewise find their place
as part of a presentation on the
autonomic nervous system
the innervation of the salivary glands
is discussed
the sub-maxillary gland is shown to be
innervated by both parasympathetic
fibers blue dotted lines and sympathetic
fibers red lines
mucus and serous cells of the gland are
stimulated by both types of fibers
sympathetic stimulation produces a
scanty viscous saliva
and parasympathetic stimulation leads to
a thinner watery saliva
it is pointed out that vaso motor
components may well have additional
effects on the quality of the secretion
histology can become a dynamic course of
study when living cells and tissue
cultures are photographed by time lapse
photography
so that the action taking place over
hours or days is compressed into seconds
on the screen
with right stain
the polymorphonuclear neutrophilic
leukocyte presents this characteristic
appearance
here the details of form and movement of
an actual living cell of the same type
are shown
since such processes cannot be seen
under normal conditions at normal speed
the motion picture alone by taking
successive pictures at regularly spaced
intervals
can record important changes in
morphology and physiology
these records over periods of time are
not only teaching aids but may be
invaluable in cancer study and research
when normal histology merges into
pathology a study of disease processes
may be recorded also by cinematography
here we are watching normal circulation
in the momentum of a rhesus monkey
a y-shaped venule is on the left
an arteriole is on the right
the flow is so fast that no individual
red cells can be seen
and the vessel lining is smooth and
clean
we now turn to photomicrography of a
momentum of a monkey infected with nolte
malaria
some of the earliest pictures of
mammalian disease ever made through a
microscope
this is a picture of what is popularly
known as sludged blood
which sloshes back and forth as the
heart fails to keep it going
this scene shows large clumps indicating
hemo concentration and a continuous loss
of plasma
severe anemia may be noted here and
white cells line the walls of the venule
the fat cells are far apart indicating
frank edema
the autopsy is a focal point of
importance to the pathologist
this sequence is part of the section on
the examination of the cranial cavity
the frontal lobes are depressed with the
left hand
as the anterior attachment of the falc
cerebri is cut from the crystal galley
the first nerve is reflected back off
the cribriform plate and the optic
nerves are cut
leaving stumps for tying the internal
carotid arteries are cut
incising the temptorium cerebelli on
either side permits the cerebellum and
brain stem to be rotated backward
this technique in which we are shown a
detailed demonstration of the removal of
the brain is but one part of the total
autopsy recorded for teaching
the bacteriologist uses motion pictures
to follow and demonstrate processes such
as growth and spread of organisms
through the microscope escherichia coli
are observed
in a dark field picture we see normal
cells short plump rods with strong
spontaneous movements
if penicillin is added to the nutrient
solution a partial inhibition of
movement appears
after one hour we find definitely
elongated rods with diminished motility
after three hours clump like distensions
of the cell body appear which are even
more marked one hour later
we can watch the development of
bacterial colonies in a solid nutrient
medium particularly well by time-lapse
photography
these normal colonies are photographed
speeded up 250 times
in the presence of penicillin cell
division is largely depressed
many changes characteristic of the
effect of various antibiotics can be
observed in this manner and give a clue
to the mode of action of these drugs
as well as indications for the
concentration which will have most
effect
an anatomist has made a unique
photographic record of ovulation in the
rat the perioverial sac has here been
opened the ovary is on the far left and
an ovum stained with methyl and blue has
already reached the entrance to the
oviduct whose fimbriated end extends
down into the perioverial space
in this scene with trance illumination
we're going to watch the actual process
of ovulation
the follicular membrane on the surface
of the ovary is becoming thin
and here we see its rupture
follicular fluid now flows out
and this is followed by some of the
granulosa cells which like the ovum have
taken up the blue stain
finally the ovum emerges enclosed in a
number of layers of follicular cells
the released egg is now carried by
ciliary activity toward the osteum
here it is transported into the
fimbriated end of the oviduct by ciliary
and muscular movements
in teaching methods of physical
diagnosis as in cancer detection
the film can demonstrate clearly and
accurately the manual skill which an
instructor wishes his students to learn
palpation of the breast is shown here
with a patient in the supine position
the flat of the hand enables the
examiner to feel as much of the breast
as possible at one time
fingertip palpation may be helpful in
the discovery of small masses
the examination should cover the nipple
and the areola and extend outwardly to
include all quadrants of the breast
palpation should be gentle but thorough
and an established pattern of
examination should be followed
all these points have been clearly
visualized in the study of orthopedics
the approach to various regions of the
body has been documented on film using
both diagram and dissection
this sequence shows the surgical
approach to the hip joint
the incision has been deepened to the
muscle layer
and the lateral femoral cutaneous nerve
has been identified and retracted
at this point the objectives are
reviewed in diagram form
the various muscles are identified
the underlying bone structure is
visualized
and structures around the joint are
described
depicting the anatomy of the region in
this manner allows for clear and slow
definition of the principles underlying
the procedure
in surgical procedures
schematic diagrams also visualize for
the student portions of an operation
which are difficult if not impossible
for the camera to see
here for instance during an operation
for mitral stenosis the steps in
performing a finger fracture of the
valve are illustrated
the right index finger has been inserted
into the opening made in the auricular
appendix
it approaches and engages the stenotic
opening of the valve
the finger is moved in an anterolateral
direction
on completion of the unilateral
commissuration
it plunges through the valve until the
middle joint fills the orifice
creating a linear fracture of the
stenotic opening
as the finger is withdrawn
the assistant pulls the purse string
suture tight
and ties it
the same procedure is followed and
illustrated in live action by the
surgeon although the finger obviously
cannot be seen inside the heart
the tip of the finger is now engaging
the valve
using the maneuver previously
illustrated the opening is enlarged
and the commissurotomy is done
diagrammatic explanation of such
procedures
adds greatly to the value of many
surgical films
endoscopic photography has been made
possible by the development of specially
designed photographic equipment
in skilled hands bronchoscopic motion
pictures have been made of a wide
variety of pathologic conditions found
on examination
this shot is of a patient with an
adenoma of the left lower lobe bronchus
the soft tumor is seen moving back and
forth with respiration
multiple papillomatile were observed in
this patient
one papilloma is seen on the vocal cord
and as the point of critical focus is
carried deeper another larger growth in
the trachea is evident
not only are pictures such as these
invaluable aids to the study of clinical
conditions but they also save lengthy
periods of observation by students
distressing to the patient and difficult
under best conditions
this patient has severe bronchial asthma
note the tremendous collapse of the
trachea carina and both main bronchi
during cough or exploration
as the scope advances down the bronchus
the film shows dramatically how the
posterior walls of the trachea and
bronchi are pushed anteriorly during
expiration
what you have seen represents a few of
the subject areas in which excellent
teaching films exist
they are available from many sources
including the library of the american
medical association
yearly requests for these come from
nearly every medical school in the
country
and the total number of films so used
continues to mount steadily
in addition the complete files of the
ama today contain records of many
hundreds of teaching films
research and experience have established
the effectiveness of films used for
teaching selected information and
concepts
as one of many media which are part of
the science of communications
the motion picture takes its place in
the medical curriculum of today
you